Demand for housing in Washington DC is going
through the roof.
Over a thousand people move into the city
every month, driving up the cost of housing
and they're turning the nation's capital into
a construction zone.
Tower cranes piercing the sky above the city
streets have become so common
they're just part of the background.
But as fast as the cranes have gone up,
demand for housing is rising even faster.
Making DC among the most expensive places
to live in the United States.
And one innovation whose time has come
shows just why the demand for housing is far
from being met.
I kinda got driven down the tiny house road
because of affordability,
simplicity, sustainability and then mobility.
Tiny houses are very cheap to build, you can
build one of these for ten thousand dollars
you can build one for thirty, forty, fifty
thousand dollars,
but they definitely come in far beneath the
cost of a regular home
especially in a city like DC.
They're very sustainable, they take very little
energy to heat or cool.
So having a space that I could hook up to
solar
that I could, you know, catch rain water and
use for a simple shower and sink
was very very appealing to me.
They are mobile because many of them are built
on wheels
but the reason they're often built on wheels
is because it then escapes
a lot of the kind of coding requirements which
these homes would violate
not because they're unsafe places to live,
but because the minimum size of a room you
know must be 120 square feet
and if these homes are 120 square feet altogether
you then have obvious issues.
This is not a tiny house, it's the Office
of Zoning, the Zoning Comission,
the Zoning Administrator, the Board of Zoning
Adjustment and the Office of Planning
which, along with the Department of Consumer
and Regulatory Affairs
implements, adjudicates and enforces 34 chapters
and 600 pages of regulations
governing property use and building requirements
int he nation's capital.
The director of the city's Office of Planning,
Ellen McCarthy,
described the problem with allowing tiny houses
in the city:
and so the zoning authorities have allowed
a few experiments in affordable housing
like this apartment made entirely from shipping
containers.
But the city is constrained by a zoning ordinance
that was drawn up in 1958
that's 56 years of cultural change and building
innovations, like tiny houses,
that the code wasn't designed to address.
and for small builders like Jay Austin, getting
a special exemption from the zoning authorities
could cost tens of thousands of dollars and
years of time
with no guarantee of success.
The proposed changes to zoning rewrite won't
effect what we're doing at all,
we are, tiny homes on wheels are still a little
bit further out
probably many years out, of decades out.
It's totally legal to buy one of these and
to park it somewhere.
And really it only becomes illegal once you
step inside and say 'this is my home.'
We could leave these houses on the lot I imagine
for 20 years
and there wouldn't be any issue with it
but if we declared these are full time residences
then there, you know,
would be a little bit more, little bit more
trouble perhaps.
The laws that keep Jay Austin from living
in his own home
have their genesis in New York City's zoning
resolution of 1916.
For the first time in history, committees
of urban planners
began to reshape an entire American city.
They split up skyscrapers to provide more
sunlight on the streets below.
Industrial factories were separated from residential
property.
Immigrant communities were kept apart from
neighborhoods of the elite.
And when the supreme court ruled these laws
didn't violate property rights,
zoning quickly spread to every major city
in America.
Every city, that is, except for one.
Houston for me is an experiment.
It's an experiment in overt capitalism.
And therefore very much at home in Texas,
there is a kind of libertarian way of thinking here.
It's much more alive in a way, much more organic,
than a typical zoned city
that is more restricted by these old fashioned
measures that no longer are viable.
If you live in an unzoned city, you have to
develop a dialogue or negotiation.
And that of course we have seen in our country
is not easy to come by.
I have architect friends that have to operate
in places like Berkeley
where the zoning board is sort of a group
of aestheticians without training
say 'that's no good, this is good, this is
Berkeley, this is not.'
And this sort of, you know, it's silliness
but has enormous economic consequences
is operating in those places.
While here, you can almost get away with anything.
Anything, like a house clad entirely in beer
cans.
In Houston a few simple laws govern lot sizes
and set backs from the street.
There's even a new historical preservation
ordinance.
But for the most part, developments are regulated
by private covenants
and deed restrictions.
And without city codes, committees or planners
to regulate land use,
all sorts of creative expression are possible.
When architects began to build homes out of
corrugated metal,
a cheap material associated with poverty and
trailer parks,
no one had the authority to stop them.
As it turned out not only were tin houses
economical,
they also kept homes cool by reflecting sunlight
during Houston's sweltering summers.
Today tin houses are cherished as a unique
Houston innovation.
Whether it's a tin house in Houston or a McMansion
in McAllen,
homes in the sprawling state of Texas
will always be cheaper than the densely populated
northeast.
But compared to the rest of the sun belt where
cities are zoned and the land is plentiful,
unregulated Houston is still the most affordable
large city in America.
I totally agree that regulation is about preventing
bad things from happening.
Houston's success in creating affordable housing
for the middle class
is one reason why the city is disparaged by
the one group whose job it makes obsolete.
Urban planners like Harriet Tregoning, formerly
of the Washington DC Office of Planning.
I hate to make Houston the whipping boy, right?
Oh go ahead.
You know, that's a place that doesn't have
zoning, it doesn't' have regulation
and it's not exactly the full flower of urbanism.
Two hours down the gulf coast from Houston
is Victoria.
A city that hasn't had zoning since it was
founded 190 years ago.
And the most unusual thing about Victoria
is that it's not very unusual at all.
I don't notice anything greatly different
about Victoria
and the look that Victoria portrays
and the look that they have in San Antonio,
Austin or Houston.
So, property rights in Texas are sacred, you
can do what you want to do with your property
and I think most of the people here in Victoria
want to protect that right.
The city's growth and land use is based more
on economics and the will of the owner
rather than some quasi-governmental body that
you have to ask permission from.
East of town was a rendering plant where they
took dead animals and processed them.
The people that were in favor of zoning would
say
'well what if there's a rendering plant next
to your house?'
Economics dictate that you're not going to
put a rendering plant
next to a residential subdivision
economics dictates that you're gonna build
a shopping center on a major thoroughfare.
It's worked very well in Victoria for a number
of years and I trust we'll continue to do so.
Now it's true if you look hard enough in Victoria
or Houston
you can find the odd high rise poking out
of a low density neighborhood
and sometimes economics dictates that you'll
have to eat your butterscotch dilly bar
next to the bail bondsman.
But tolerating a little disharmony, a dash
of kitsch
and the occasional strip club in a strip mall
along the Texas gulf coast
is a small down payment on the right to be
the architect of your own life.
Because if you're Jay Austin, you can build
the home of your dreams,
you just can't live there.
For now his tiny house is a part time residence
and a full time showpiece
to present to the public in the hopes of changing
a zoning committe
that hasn't updated a zoning code in 56 years.